I got a very interesting email voicemail,
rather, about twenty twenty four. You can
call my voicemail number any time of day and many
of you do the number of voicemails we get in the
middle of the night. Stunning. Here's one about
twenty, twenty four to one nine two. David P.
is the number.
Hi, David, on this the first question,
and I'm calling from Kalamazoo, Michigan, and
I was wondering the entire Trump impeachment
scenario that's going on. Yes. What do
you think it means for this country that.
All the evidence that was shown.
The footage of the riot and the
break in at the Capitol and somehow he was
still acquitted by I say about this country.
Does it worry you? Because I'm really afraid,
like if he can get a job or something like that,
what are you going to do in twenty, twenty four
open like a Trump junior run right into office?
I'm terrified. What do you think it says about
this country and where are we going? Thanks.
Yeah, one of the most disgusting. I guess we have
to call them realities that we have to accept
is that when you look at the Republican vote to
acquit in the Senate and then you look at Trump's
letter saying, I'm sticking around and we've got
a lot of stuff planned for the next few months,
and you see that 64 percent of Republicans in a
recent poll, 70 percent of Republicans in another
recent poll say if Trump created his own party,
I would leave the GOP and join the Trump Party.
What you can you have no choice but to accept
that a Trump like figure could indeed win again
in 2020. For now, the hope is that if there's a
split between Trump and the Republican Party, that
they do damage to each other. And you could have
a sort of cannibalistic effect where Trump takes
some of the Republican Party Trump or a Trump
then candidate, maybe Trump Jr., maybe Ivanka,
maybe Marjorie Taylor Greene, who knows, they run
and they take a bunch of the vote. And then you've
got the Republican vote, which is damaged. And
then you end up with a situation like the Ross
Perot situation of the early 90s with the Democrat
winning that. That's the ideal scenario. Now,
there are people who will look at that and say,
you know, the math could work out differently.
And I understand that. But if 64 percent
of the country is willing to follow Trump,
we all have to recognize that that is exactly the
concern with not ridding ourselves of this problem
right away. And how could we when tens of millions
of people continue to support it? So, yeah,
the caller is absolutely right in her concern.
We have a great bonus show today. We are going
to talk about, you know, I get emails all the
time from people from from the trolls. David,
why won't you ever talk about what's going on
with Andrew Cuomo in New York? Because Andrew
Cuomo doesn't seem to be managing a lot of things
correctly and there's a lot of things coming out.
We've been covering it from the beginning. And we
will again cover how the covid-19 story is getting
even worse for Democratic New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo. That's on today's bonus show.
Also on the bonus show, the Boeing 737, Max, is
flying again and it's very quietly flying again.
And we're going to talk about how airlines have
brought it back because it has been cleared,
but they're not advertising it. And it's obvious
why lots of people still aren't interested if they
are going back to flying at this point during the
pandemic. They're not interested in flying on the
737, Max. But it is back. And I'm going to tell I
have a kind of a personal story about this myself.
We will also talk about how the Supreme Court
has stayed the execution of an Alabama inmate who
has requested a pastor's presence. The details
are very interesting and we will discuss that
and more on today's bonus show. Get
instant access by becoming a member
at Join Pakman Dotcom. You can use the coupon
code if you so please, to get a discount.
The coupon code is better. Twenty one. You can
also get instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a patron at Patreon dot com slash David
Pakman show. I will see you on the bonus show.
Sadly, if you don't have access to the bonus
show, we will meet again tomorrow See you then.